when people talk about actors undergoing
physical transformations for a role they
often focus on stars who put on a bunch
of weight or work out a ton but acting
ain't just about the body in fact an
actor's most important feature is his or
her face ever since the dawn of cinema
movie stars have been using makeup to
alter their appearance and with the help
of a fake nose or an artificial forehead
an actor can transform into a completely
different being altogether here are some
of the most memorable examples Tilda
Swinton snowpiercer
in addition to having truckloads of
talent Tilda Swinton is something of a
shape-shifter and for our money her most
radical facial transformation was for
the Korean thriller snowpiercer the film
sees the actress played the nefarious
Minister Mason a grotesque politician
with some of the ugliest teeth in cinema
originally the part was written for a
man but director bong joon-ho really
wanted Swinton to try the part on for
size so with the help of makeup designer
Jeremy Woodhead Swinton created a
uniquely ugly character really the
makeup seems so simple a pair of
dentures a floppy wig a prosthetic nose
but if the actress had gotten her way
Minister Mason would have looked even
worse according to the director Swinton
originally wanted the slimy spokesperson
to sport a pig's nose but he explained
that was just a bit too much even for
snowpiercer Halle Berry Cloud Atlas
2012's Cloud Atlas is a wildly ambitious
sci-fi flick of epic proportions from
the acclaimed directing team of lana and
lily wachowski the film follows a select
group of souls as they continually cross
paths across time with various actors
undergoing radical transformations
changing race and gender from scene to
scene the decision was controversial
with critics arguing over whether the
movie was racially insensitive or
progressive but regardless of how you
feel about the Wachowskis vision you
have to admire the dedication of the
actors with Halle Berry
absolutely disappearing into not one but
six different roles over the course of
nearly three hours berry plays a grand
total of six roles each one radically
different from the last while she
impresses with all of her performances
the two that truly stand out are a
german-jewish woman and an ancient
Korean man to play the German woman in
1936 Barry underwent 8 hours of
intensive work which involved everything
from a prosthetic nose to skin
lightening treatments but her most
memorable appearance is definite
the ghoulish Korean doctor in 21:44 she
sat in the makeup chair for six hours
and while she had a lot of fun with this
transformation
she told Entertainment Weekly that the
teeth were just horrific the cast of Fox
catcher when Fox catcher hit theaters in
2014
everybody noticed Steve Carell schnoz
the actor drew quite a bit of flack for
his fake nose but he really did look
almost identical to real-life murderer
John DuPont and the nose is just the tip
of the cosmetics iceberg when it comes
to Fox catcher makeup artist bill Corso
also masked corrals eyebrows with a
prosthetic forehead lightened his skin
tone and even built him a fake lip to
top everything off Corso gave Carell a
pair of dark contact lenses that really
helped him slip into the role of an
obsessive multi-millionaire but while
Carell gets all the attention
Channing Tatum and Mark Ruffalo also
underwent some pretty impressive facial
transformations to look like genuine
wrestlers Tatum was given fake
cauliflower ears and a bridge to enlarge
his nose in his nostrils and lips were
widened with special prosthetics called
plumpers similarly Ruffalo had
prosthetics stuck behind his upper lip
and underwent frequent haircuts to
capture wrestler Dave Schultz his
balding hairline he also had little
brackets placed in the back of his ears
to make them stick out so that he looked
more like Tatum Gary Oldman Hannibal
Hannibal Lecter is one of the most
famous cinematic serial killers of all
time but he isn't the only murderer
stalking his franchise in the 2001 film
Hannibal the sinister Mason Verger is
one of the few people who've survived an
encounter with the liver-eating
psychiatrist of course he didn't escape
from Lecter totally intact as the
sophisticated killer absolutely
demolished Verger 'he's face so when it
came time to put script to screen makeup
artist greg cannom needed to turn actor
gary oldman into a veritable monster
using a special translucent silicone
Khanum transformed Oldman into a lipless
monster covered in scars and putrified
flesh the whole ghoulish process took
around 6 hours but perhaps the best
touch came from the mind of Oldman
himself the actor wanted to give Verger
and I that was permanently open so
kannan put together a set up involving a
silk cloth velcro and a little wire that
prevented Altman's eyelids from shutting
he also inserted a nasty-looking contact
lens and had someone stand by with
eyedrops to keep the actor from losing
his vision
yikes Glenn Close Albert Nobbs
the story of a victorian-era woman
living as a man 2011's Albert Nobbs was
an incredibly personal film for Glenn
Close
she'd first played the role back in 1982
in an off-broadway show and she wanted
to share the story on the silver screen
for years to pull it off she needed to
disguise her face to inhabit her dream
role so she turned to makeup expert
Matthew Mungle for a helping hand Mangal
wanted the makeup to be incredibly
subtle he based the design largely off a
photo the clothes had found of a manly
woman from the 30s working with
prosthetic pieces and dental plumpers he
kept things relatively simple which he
claimed is a lot more difficult than it
sounds he told the Los Angeles Times to
put a nose on someone's face and blended
into their skin and make it look natural
is harder than wearing a whole NASK
so with just a few touches here and
there clothes stepped out of the makeup
chair a new man in fact when she finally
looked in the mirror she was so
overwhelmed that she began crying